Rihanna still may not have released her next album,...
...but according to new reports, she just surpassed billionaire status...
...making her the richest female musician in the world.
Let's get into it.
If you're a fan of Rihanna's,...
...you know that we've been anxiously awaiting new music from RiRi...
...for over five years now.
Her last album Anti came out in 2016,...
...but since then, Rihanna's focus has been her businesses,...
...including her makeup brand Fenty Beauty and lingerie brand Savage X Fenty.
And while we are all craving new music,...
...Rihanna really has been killing it as a businesswoman,...
...so much so that Forbes just revealed that she is officially a billionaire...
...with her net worth reportedly clocking in at a whopping 1.7 billion dollars!
This massive net worth makes Rihanna the richest female musician in the world...
...and the second richest female entertainer behind none other than Oprah Winfrey.
For now, congrats to RiRi on becoming a billionaire!
She did that!